[Musik]
Gebäude stürzen zusammen Menschen werden
unter den Trümmern begraben die
verheerenden Erdbeben seit Jahrzehnten
treffen die Grenzregion zwischen der
Türkei und Syrien mindestens 2500
Menschen sterben und bei eisigen
Temperaturen suchen verzweifelte
Überlebende in den Schuttbergen nach
Ihrem Angehörigen
wir schauen ausführlich dorthin den
Sport hat später in der Sendung Norbert
Lehmann guten Abend als erstes aber der
Blick nach Syrien und in die Türkei
mindestens 2500 Menschen sind bei den
Erdbeben ums Leben gekommen und rund
12.000 verletzt worden aber es wird
befürchtet dass die Zahlen weiter
steigen werden dennoch immer sind viele
Menschen verschüttet
das erste schwere Beben kam mitten in
der Nacht mit einer Stärke von 7,7 das
Epizentrum lag in der Provinz
karaman-marash Nadel syrischen Grenze
dort gab es weitere starke Nachbeben
auch die über Nachbarn Provinzen Geysir
sind schwer betroffen bluten
sie laufen um ihr Leben als eines der
vielen Nachbeben Malatya erschüttert
auch in Jeanne weiter südlich stürzen
diesem Moment vieles in sich zusammen
dass die ersten Stöße in der Nacht noch
überstanden hatte
180 Kilometer nordöstlich wird das
anatolische Djerba Kia ebenfalls schwer
getroffen weite Teile gleich in einem
Trümmerfeld
ich schlief als meine Frau mich
plötzlich weckte das Beben war äußerst
stark und sehr beängstigend es hat fast
zwei Minuten lang gedauert bis die Stöße
wieder aufhörten
bereits Stunden vor Sonnenaufgang hatte
das erste Beben die Menschen aus dem
Schlaf gerissen
seither versuchen Rettungskräfte und
freiwillige Überlebende aus den Trümmern
zu ziehen viel Zeit bleibt nicht auch
wegen der Eiseskälte
die Leute verlassen halt ihre Gebäude
und trauen sich jetzt nicht mehr rein
weil es halt ständig weiter wackelt ja
und das ist in der Türkei schlimm aber
da können die Leute noch in ihr Auto
gehen im Notfall wenn sie ans haben in
Syrien
ist eh kaputt ja da ist die Lage der
Leute jetzt mit Sicherheit noch mal
schlimmer tatsächlich sind die Folgen
des Bebens auf der syrischen Seite der
Grenze noch gravierender in der Stadt
schien die es im Nordwesten wühlen sich
die Menschen verzweifelt durch die
Schuttberge
[Applaus]
darunter liegen 12 Familien keiner hat
es raus geschafft sie sind alle noch
drin niemand war hier zu schauen wie es
den Menschen geht wir graben mit unseren
Händen seit 3 Uhr morgens
das Erdbeben trifft eine ohnehin vom
langen Krieg ausgezehrte Region die
syrische Rettungsorganisation weißhelme
spricht von hunderten Toten
Nordwest Syrien ist Katastrophengebiet
wir brauchen Hilfe von allen um unsere
Menschen zu retten
manchmal gibt es kleine Lichtblicke nahe
Aleppo gelang es den Rettern ein Kind
lebend aus den Tiefen eines trümmerbergs
zu ziehen ein kurzer Moment des Glücks
inmitten einer furchtbaren Katastrophe
il nach Kairo zuerst zu ihnen eine wie
kommt eine Türkei die Bergung der
Verschütteten voran
ja hier in der Türkei ist es ja bereits
kurz nach 21 Uhr und natürlich laufen
die Rettungsarbeiten auch die ganze
Nacht weiter die ersten 72 Stunden sind
ja entscheidend wenn es darum geht noch
Verschüttete zu bergen
1.650 Tote gibt es bislang zu vermelden
2800 Gebäude sind eingestürzt und noch
nicht zu allen konnten die Retter
wirklich auch vordringen
insgesamt sind ist die Region von
Nachbeben erschüttert Straßen sind
zerstört Brücken die Flughäfen das macht
es für weitere Rettungsteams auch schwer
in die Region zu kommen ein anderer
Faktor ist das sehr schlechte Wetter es
schneit es regnet bei Temperaturen um
den Gefrierpunkt und viele Überlebende
verbringen diese Nacht unter diesen
Bedingungen im Freien das türkische
Militär hat eine Luftbrücke errichtet
mit Hilfslieferungen Zelten Decken Öfen
und natürlich hoffen die Menschen auch
auf die internationale Hilfe die ja
bereits angelaufen offen ist
Collini in Syrien herrscht der
Bürgerkrieg wie bekommen die Menschen in
Erdbebengebieten da Hilfe
die am stärksten betroffene Region in
Syrien ist zweifelsohne Nordwest Syrien
das ist eine normalerweise fast
abgeriegelte Region wo vier bis fünf
Millionen Syrer Leben zumeist als
Vertriebene als Flüchtlinge und zwar in
schon vom Krieg zerstörte Infrastruktur
und jetzt gibt es quasi eine Krise in
der Krise wer in Zelten gelebt hat der
hat zumeist Glück gehabt aber es gibt
ganze Ortschaften mit zementierten
flüchtlingsbehausungen die gänzlich
kollabiert sind es sind Kliniken
überlastet Patienten auch Neugeborene
mussten
schwere Notfälle können nicht mehr wie
üblich in der Türkei behandelt werden in
jedem Dorf in jeder kleineren und
größeren Stadt gibt es verschüttete
berichten die Helfer hunderte wenn ich
da tausende das sagt die
Zivilschutzorganisation der weiß Helme
das sind ungefähr 3000 Helfer aber sie
haben oft nicht die geeignete
hilfsausrüstung und sie haben nur
begrenzte Reserven das heißt sie sind
dringend sagen sie auf internationale
Hilfe angewiesen wenn es keine schnelle
keine umfassende internationale
hilfsintervention für Nordwest Syrien
gibt dann kann es sein dass die Hilfe
für die Menschen dort zu spät kommt
danke kulinartei und Anne brüll
das ist im türkisch-syrischen
Grenzgebiet zu so schweren Erdbeben
gekommen ist liegt daran dass sich
Erdplatten verschoben haben ganzer
Scholz hat den Opfern jetzt schnelle
Hilfe zugesagt man koordiniere sich
gerade mit der türkischen Regierung aber
auch mit allen anderen die helfen wollen
mehr von Thomas gonzia
auch dieser Hund soll Leben retten
verschüttete vermisste finden er gehört
zu einem Team der Organisation Isa in
Nordrhein-Westfalen das kommt und bringt
Zelte Medikamente
Infusionslösung Hilfe aus Hünxe für
dringende Erstversorgung möglichst
schnell
wir haben nur eine gewisse Anzahl von
Stunden Zeit wirklich Überlebende unter
den Trümmern zu finden gerade bei den
Wetterbedingungen doch mit solchen
Problemen kennen sich die
Hilfsorganisationen aus kennen sich aus
mit Katastrophen in der Türkei denn kaum
ein Land erleidet so viele Erdbeben
Grund gleich fünf Erdplatten stoßen dort
aufeinander
zwei sind für das Geschehen nun
verantwortlich die anatolische und die
arabische die Platten verschieben sich
mit bis zu 2 cm pro Jahr sie drücken
gegeneinander sie verhaken sich wird
dann die Spannung zu groß entstehen
Brüche und Erdbeben zuletzt wurde die
Region vor drei Jahren erschüttert die
Provinz ellerse 41 Menschen kamen ums
Leben schlimm aber wenig im Vergleich zu
den Erdstößen jetzt denn die sind nicht
nur punktuell sagen Geologen sondern
großflächig das zeigen die Daten
daraus können wir in etwa die
Bruchfläche von ca 200 Kilometern
abschätzen im Untergrund die gerissen
ist in dem Bereich war seit etwa 1.000
Jahren kein so großes Ereignis mehr
aufgestaute und umso heftigere Beben
also gewissermaßen wie das an der Grenze
zur eurasischen Platte unweit von
Istanbul 1999 die Todeszahl damals mehr
als 17.000
zu den Erdbeben und den Folgen gibt es
auch ein ZDF Spezial gleich hier im
Anschluss an diese Sendung und wenn sie
den Menschen helfen wollen sie können
Spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die iban.de
65-100 400
6100 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei
Syrien informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
wie soll das Spitzen Treffen zum Thema
Flucht und Migration aussehen dass
Innenministerin Veser plant da gibt es
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
Opposition und Landkreise fordern einen
Gipfel auf höchster Ebene mit Kanzler
Scholz schließlich gehe es bei der
Unterbringung von geflüchteten auch um
viel Geld nach bisherigen Stand wird
Scholz aber nicht an den Beratung
teilnehmen das Treffen soll noch im
Februar stattfinden
heute vor zehn Jahren gründete sich die
Alternative für Deutschland die AFD
protestiert zunächst vor allem gegen die
Euro-Rettung an der Spitze damals
Wirtschaftsprofessor Bernd Lucke in den
folgenden Jahren steht die AFD zunehmend
rechts wird unter dem aktuellen
führungsdauer vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet bei Bundestagswahlen hat sich
die AFD mittlerweile etabliert im
zdf-mann und David Gebhard berichten
Königstein im Taunus draußen Proteste
drinnen Feststimmung die AFD schweigt in
Superlativen
zehn Jahre
Alternative für Deutschland das ist eine
Erfolgsgeschichte
wie es sie nicht gegeben hat seit die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland besteht rund
10 km entfernt in oberurselfing alles an
hier in diesem Saal der Kirchengemeinde
gründeten 18 Männer am 6 februar 2013
die AFD mitten in der Eurokrise und als
Reaktion auf Angela Merkels dictum die
Rettung des Euros und Griechenlands sein
alternativlos
dieses Wort von der Kanzlerin
alternativlos zu sein lehnen Sie also
mit abscher und Empörung ab weil sie
eigentlich dafür sind dass wir aus dem
Euro austreten es gibt überhaupt nichts
auf der Welt was wirklich alternativlos
ist man muss alternativen formulieren
man muss sich vergleichen die Eurokrise
App ab die AFD sucht sich neue Themen
erst Flüchtlinge später Corona nun den
Ukraine Krieg stets auf Konfrontation zu
den anderen Parteien im Laufe der Zeit
radikalisiert sich die Partei dermaßen
stark dass der Verfassungsschutz sie
inzwischen beobachtet viele ihrer
Anhänger stört das nicht und so erhebt
man offen den Machtanspruch
darum glaube ich dass wir übernächstes
Jahr aller spätestens in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern wo wir jetzt
schon stärkste Kraft sind dass wir dort
auch durchstoßen mit einer realistischen
regierungsperspektive eine realistische
macht Option ist jedoch mehr als
fraglich die anderen Parteien wollen mit
der AFD nicht koalieren zehn Jahre nach
ihrer Gründung blickt die Partei auf
gute Umfragen und auf viele Brandmauern
weiße Rose stand auf ihren Flugblättern
und so nannte sich eine der bekanntesten
deutschen Widerstandsgruppen gegen das
nationalsozialistische Regime im Februar
vor 80 Jahren wurden drei Mitglieder
darunter die Geschwister Hans und Sophie
Scholl von den Nazis hingerichtet
Bundespräsident Steinmeier erinnerte
heute an die Widerstandsgruppe im
Lichthof der Münchner Uni die Demokratie
in Deutschland seien den vergangenen
Jahren stärker unter Druck geraten so
Steinmeier
verfassungsgegnern soll es nicht noch
einmal gelingen können Sie im Innersten
anzugreifen
die neu aufgeflammte Gewalt in der OST
reist nicht ab bei einer radie an einem
Flüchtlingslager im Westjordanland haben
israelische Soldaten 5 bewaffnete
Palästinenser erschossen nach eigenen
Angaben erwiderten die Militärs das
Feuer nachdem sie dort selbst
angegriffen worden waren eigentlich
hatten sie zwei militante Palästinenser
festnehmen wollen sie sollen versucht
haben einen Anschlag auf israelische
Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten zu verüben
die radikalislamische Maß spricht von
einem Massaker und kündigte Vergeltung
an
heute ist der internationale Tag gegen
weibliche Genitalverstümmelung eine
grausame Praxis die in einigen Ländern
nach wie vor verbreitet ist so gibt es
mehr als 200 Millionen Betroffene
Mädchen und Frauen in 31 Ländern laut
dem Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten
Nationen Susann von Lojewski berichtet
aus Kenia wo Genitalverstümmelung
eigentlich gesetzlich verboten ist
wenn Justin kulia kommt dann versammeln
sich die BewohnerInnen von Marella
central Kenia auf dem Dorfplatz und
hören ihr aufmerksam zu mit gerade
einmal acht Jahren wurde sie genital
verstümmelt als Erwachsene kämpft sie
nun mit ihrer Stiftung gegen das blutige
Ritual
wir retten Mädchen vor
Genitalverstümmelungen Kinder Heirat die
Menschen denken das ist gegen ihre
Kulturen sogar ihre Führer sprechen
nicht darüber weil sie denken dass sie
nicht wiedergewählt werden aber ich
spreche darüber
Stiftung betreibt auch eine Schule die
Mädchen bekommen eine Ausbildung alle
hier sollten ganz jung verheiratet
werden und dann am Tag ihrer Hochzeit
genital verstümmelt werden alle aber
konnten gerettet werden
ich habe die Ziegen gehütet und dann hat
mein Vater mich weggegeben meine Mutter
hat mir gesagt ich werde verheiratet
mein Onkel hat das gehört und mich
hierher gebracht
eigentlich gibt es seit elf Jahren in
Kenia ein Gesetz gegen
Genitalverstümmelung mindestens drei
Jahre gefängnistrohen den Täterinnen
doch noch immer folgen Gemeinden im
Verborgenen der Tradition
es ist wichtig die Männer stärker
einzubeziehen denn sie sind auch die
Türsteher zu Kulturen und Traditionen
und sie sind religiöse Führer und
Gemeindeleiter es ist wichtig sie mit
ins Boot zu holen
justin couleier hat mit ihrer Stiftung
den Mädchen eine Perspektive gegeben die
eine selbstbestimmten Lebens
Staus hat heute morgen nicht nur der
Berufsverkehr ausgelöst auch die
sogenannte letzte Generation war wieder
aktiv Mitglieder der klimaschutzbewegung
klebten sich in mehreren Städten auf
Straßenfest wie hier in Düsseldorf
ähnliche Aktionen gab es unter anderem
in Hannover Leipzig und Berlin die
Polizei erstattete Anzeigen gegen
mehrere protestierende die letzte
Generation will ihre Blockaden in den
nächsten Wochen noch ausweiten
mehr als 5.000 Beschäftigte der Post
haben heute wieder an Warnstreiks
teilgenommen wie hier in Brandenburg
legten zustellerinnen und Mitarbeiter
von Verteilzentren die Arbeit nieder die
Gewerkschaft verdi fordert 15% mehr Lohn
und begründet das vor allem mit der
hohen Inflation
Mittwoch sollen die Tarifverhandlungen
weitergehen die Post will dann ein
Angebot für die 160.000 Beschäftigten
vorliegen
wenn alle Musik Stars an einem Ort sind
heißt das es werden wieder die Grammys
verlieren eine der wichtigsten
Musikpreise der USA Sängerin Beyonce
brach dabei gestern Abend in Los Angeles
einen Rekord auch eine deutsche wurde
ausgezeichnet und besonders gefeiert
wurde 50 Jahre Hip-Hop über die Musik
und auch die politischen Töne berichtet
Johannes
[Musik]
es war eine Show so bunt divers
vielfältig und wild wie schon lange
nicht mehr Energie geladener Höhepunkt
die Performance zum 50-jährigen Hip Hop
Jubiläum
und die Stars der Szene waren alle da
Moderator der showtreffer Noah ließ kein
Zweifel daran worum es an diesem Abend
ging Music ist nicht nur die Harmonie
von Sound sondern auch die Harmonie der
Menschen verschiedene Herkunft
Geschlechter Religionen und sexuelle
Orientierung
[Musik]
der Grammy für das beste pop-doo ging an
non binär Sam Smith und die deutsche
Transfrau Kim Petras für ihren Song
anholen
nehme denn ich bin die erste Transgender
Frau die ein Grammy gewinnt
[Applaus]
US-Präsidenten verliehen neu
geschaffenen Preis bester Song für
sozialen Wandel und der ging an den
Iraner Chevin haribour der Iran im
Gefängnis sitzt
der Rapper Kendrick Lamar und die
Jazzsängerin Samara Joy wurden
ausgezeichnet der Preis für das beste
Album ging an Harry Styles mit vier
Grammys an diesem Abend aber wurde
Beyoncés und greatest of all time
niemand hat jetzt mehr Grammys gewonnen
als Queen beef 32 insgesamt
nicht schlecht wir kommen zum Auftakt
der ski-alpine Norbert und der beginnt
damit eine Herd Enttäuschung für
Michaela Chefin der ausgeschieden ist
sie knapp vor dem Ziel im zweiten Lauf
die Titel Verteidigerin und 85 malige
weltcupsiegerin aus den USA des Einheit
des anderen freut so gewann eine
Italienerin das erste Gold bei dieser WM
ist auch ihr erstes WM Gold
Fassungslosigkeit bei Federica brillione
sie ist die erste Titelträgerin dieser
WM was in meiner Karriere noch gefehlt
hat war eine Goldmedaille und ich bin so
aufgeregt und glücklich über den
heutigen Tag
in der alpine Kombination fährt die
32-Jährige Italienerin am Morgen im
Super G von Mary Bell Bestzeit am
Nachmittag bleibt brillionen nach einem
überraschend guten Slalom in
dann die Szene des Tages die große top
Favoritin Micaela shiffrin aus den USA
faded kurz vor Schluss ein und scheidet
aus Gold verbrennunion Silber gewinnt
wenn die Holdener aus der Schweiz Bronze
die Österreicherin Ricarda die einzige
deutsche Teilnehmerin immer Eicher
landet am Ende auf Platz 8
zur Fußball-Bundesliga im zweiten
Sonntagsspiel der erste Liga Sieg der
Bayern in diesem Jahr 142 Wolfsburg
überragende Münchner mit drei Treffern
in 19 Minuten zu Beginn ja und am Ende
setzt den Unterzahl noch mit einem
Traumtor
allein gegen ein Rudel Wölfe Jamal
musiala lässt sich davon nicht
beeindrucken er schlängelt sich durch
die Wolfsburger Abwehr ein fantastisches
solo zum 4:1
unbeeindruckt von der Unterzahl ebenso
das gesamte bayern-team nach Gelb-Rot
für Kimmich ein furioser Beginn der
Münchner mit zwei Treffern von command
und eine Frau Müller 3:0 im Nachhinein
wichtig
wir wussten natürlich schon dass
Wolfsburg eigentlich ja wenn man das
Jahr 23
sich anschaut schon eine Mannschaft mit
Form ist denn die 11 von Nico Kovac mit
vielen Chancen aber selteneren Treffern
das zwei zu vier durchfahrenberg Siege
wie dieser halten die Unruhe in München
auf kleiner Flamme
[Applaus]
ja und alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des
Spieltags zu sehen bei heute.de und in
der heute App auch der letzte Auftritt
von der hoffenheimstrainer Breitenreiter
am Samstag die 2:5 Klatsche in Bochum
heute beurlaubte die TSG ihren Coach
nach zehn sieglosen Pflichtspielen in
Serie ein Nachfolger steht noch nicht
fest
Hoffenheim jetzt nur noch Tabellen 14
und im Abstiegskampf
mit hohem Luftdruck wird es sonniger und
ruhiger mehr dazu gleich beim Wetter von
besten Herrli Marietta Slomka hatte
21:45
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bevor wir nach
Deutschland schauen kurzer Blick
Richtung Türkei in die Erdbebengebiete
die gibt es noch Regen und Schnee und
das lässt erst in den Frühstunden nach
aber frostig bleibt es teilweise immer
noch bei uns gibt's noch etwas
Schneefall in der Nacht das wird dann
weniger werden und dann wird's Trockner
nach Norden hin bildet sich Hochnebel
das in der kommenden nachts nach Osten
hin und Südosten ist es aufgeklärt jeder
Schnee Richtung Oberrhein der lässt
allmählich nach bei Temperaturen die
ordentlich in den Keller sagten minus 14
Grad strenger vor Frost im Südosten und
minus ein Grad Richtung Nordsee Morgen
viel Sonnenschein in der Südhälfte nach
Norden hin ist der Hochnebel noch
relativ dicht löst sich aber allmählich
auf größten Temperaturen von null Grad
an den Alpen und sechs Grads ganz im
Westen Richtung Niederrhein Blick auf
die nächsten Tage viel Sonnenschein
bleibt am Mittwoch dazu kräftiger
Ostwind der ist recht bös - ein bis
sieben Grad und am Donnerstag gibt es
etwas Regen im Norden und Freitag sogar
ein paar Schneeflocken damit ein schöner
Abend